[Music]
when the end of eternals hits it's as if
someone picked an enormous white
dandelion and blue on it scattering its
seeds all over the universe if your head
is still spinning you've come to the
right place this is the end of eternals
eternal's assembled
most of eternals is concerned with the
emergence an event triggered by the
energy expelled when half of the world's
population was snapped back into
existence in avengers endgame this
caused a literal earthquake that once
again gave rise to the deviants mortal
foes of the eternals and began
triggering a series of events that would
lead to the celestial's newly revealed
long game bringing an end to human life
through the emergence of tiamat a
celestial egg planted eons ago who has
been feeding off human evolution all
this time to paraphrase one character
all along the eternals have been
basically farming humans as food for the
celestials the emergence begins marked
by an exploding volcano and the site of
tiamat seemingly rising up from the
center of the planet just as his hand
and part of his head begins to emerge
he's turned to marble at this point the
eternals are fractured icarus has
revealed his cruel intentions and that
he murdered ajac and sprite has let
puppy love get the better of her joining
icarus in a quest to assist the
celestials as they bring about the end
of mankind meanwhile a conflicted king
go has bailed and with another recently
deceased that leaves cersei fastos druid
and makari to fight the good fight
as speculated by fastos the remaining
eternals can unite their power to create
what he calls the unimined first
introduced by jack kirby in 1977's
eternals number 12 the uni mind has
served the group over the years as their
weapon of choice against the celestials
so it's only appropriate that they
deploy it here in the comics the uni
mind has often been depicted as a being
of light and energy in the film the
group emanates yellow tendrils of energy
that link them together since at this
point cersei is the prime eternal she is
the principal beneficiary of the
unimined in the comics typically only
the prime eternal can summon it when
fastos is able to contain icarus on the
beach and druid delivers a crushing blow
to the duplicitous sprite it frees up
the remaining eternals to maximize their
unimined potential stopping the
emergence in its tracks and seemingly
saving the day
while a lot of this is going on athena
finds herself grappling with the deviant
warlord crow presented in this film as
being essentially the most powerful
deviant of course she's also grappling
with issues of mind and memory as she's
been throughout most of the film only
now the audience understands that her
memory issues aren't so much in
inability to remember as an inability to
forget crow has a weapon the other
deviants do not wield he can speak which
means he can manipulate throughout their
epic battle crow attempts to confuse and
even befriend the eternal and as her
eyes glaze over it looks like his tactic
might be working by the end of their
confrontation dina is wrapped up in
crow's tendrils about to have her energy
drained much like ajax before her but
our girl has a trick up her sleeve as
seemingly the last moment xena activates
her golden spear she wields throughout
the film which doesn't seem to be an
object so much as it is a manifestation
of her cosmic powers and slices crow
into several pieces one of the cool
things about this scene is that in the
comics dina and crow were romantic
partners for thousands of years it was a
relationship that was forbidden since
both the eternals and deviants are sworn
enemies but if you're aware of such a
storyline the scene probably played even
better because you may have thought
there was a chance crow and fina could
indeed come together
with the day seemingly saved and the
emergence seemingly avoided one group of
eternals returned to the domo to head
off in search of their next adventure
while another group stays behind on
earth it is the latter group that feeds
one of the film's cliffhangers just as
cersei seems to be reunited with dane
whitman and preparing for her happily
ever after she is literally snatched off
the planet by a vengeful irishm who
holds the earthbound eternals before him
speaking to them in space with their
planet now relegated to the background
of the shot as it turns out big surprise
perishing isn't thrilled by how the
eternals betrayed their supposed duty he
also isn't nearly so easy to defeat in
battle which is why he now holds the
eternals before him as if they were
misbehaving mice promising to return for
judgment as if that statement isn't
ominous enough in the comics ereshum is
often referred to as ereshim the judge
and it isn't because he has a tendency
to let people off with a slap on the
wrist and a stern warning typically he
has the ability to judge which planet's
civilizations will live and die and is
the most powerful of the celestial hosts
the bottom line when some future mcu
movie presents erisham's judgment it
most likely will not be good news
after a few dozen names scroll past the
screen lights back up to reveal the
interior of the domo where our space
traveling eternals have received word
that their counterparts on earth are
being judged by airshow it's just then
that a cosmic event occurs depositing
two space travelers into their ship pip
a smart alky small and stature cg
character voiced by patton oswalt
introduces harry styles as eros the
royal prince of titan aka thanos's
brother
i love those guys
for marvel fans all of this is big news
eros is a very unorthodox character in
the comics known primarily for his
hedonistic lifestyle and hard partying
ways in the comics he went on to join
the avengers where he earned the new
earthbound name star fox and became as
adept as putting down baddies as he was
at betting women although they don't get
into all this in the post-credits scene
eros is the son of two eternals himself
has frequently battled thanos and has
comic book connections to such
characters as ultron and the upcoming
disney plus series star she-hulk not to
be overshadowed is pip who seems to be
serving as a valet for arrows pip is a
character some fans have been clamoring
for and there was a substantial
groundswell not long ago to get peter
dinklage cast in the part arrow says to
the eternals as the scene concludes your
friends are in big trouble and we know
how to find them
in the second post-credits scene we see
the payoff for a tease that dane whitman
seemed to be making at the end of the
film as he was reunited with cersei who
was eager to reveal all about her
world-saving adventure and desire to
remain on earth harrington's dane had
his own revelation to make saying that
his family history is complicated that
conversation was interrupted perhaps
forever when ereshim rudely interrupted
and swept cersei away for intergalactic
judgment in the second post-credits
moment we see a conflicted dane in what
looks to be a university building room
or library examining a strange looking
box inside is a sword undoubtedly the
magical ebony blade which seems to be
activating itself as dane says death is
my reward and i'm sorry i have to try
just as something is about to happen an
off-camera voice indicates that someone
substantial has entered the room
undetected are you sure you're ready for
that the voice asks seemingly
interrupting dane's ritual what does it
mean
well dane whitman is the name of an
incarnation of the black knight a marvel
character dating back to 1967's the
avengers number 47. in a nutshell this
character inherited a mystical sword
wielded by others who bore the same
moniker using it for both good and bad
this family history goes all the way
back to the time of king arthur and the
dane whitman character assists the
avengers frequently perhaps most notably
against kang the conqueror supposedly
the big bad of this newest marvel phase
also the ebony blade has been known to
allow its wielder to travel across
various time streams which could be very
handy in a fractured multiverse the
ebony blade was originally supposed to
appear as an easter egg in 2016's doctor
strange but was dropped at some point we
might see the black knight sooner than
you'd think as rumor has it that
harrington will appear in 2022's doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
eternals are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you